they say the russians are preparing an
all-out assault on the towns and cities
of eastern ukraine
but the war has already come to severo
donetsk
an embattled city of ghosts and
apparitions the community sits on the
edge of the unknown
we met the police unit who work the
district that adjoins the front line
and we soon found ourselves running for
cover the area is deeply unstable
their mission to save the lives of those
who live here
but first we had to huddle behind a wall
after a few minutes we were given the
all clear
there are about 30 people in this school
and
these police officers are going to bring
them out now
and it
it looks like hell on earth around here
officers think there are city residents
hiding in local schools
but they struggle to find them on the
premises
with constant shelling there's not much
time
[Music]
a group both cold and hungry clustering
around a fire
living in a dark and precarious corner
the police encouraged them to leave
but only two take up the offer
how long have you been living in this
school
one month seven days
nobody knows how many people are left in
severo donetsk
there are sick people living in this
overcrowded cellar but they refuse to
evacuate it
some are scared others do not trust the
police
but there are others like 84 year old
tamara trey
who have made the decision to flee
and she was carried to the vehicle at
speed in the arms of an officer
it's wonderful she said
yeah
it's scary isn't it it's very
frightening
how long have you been
foreign
there is a building on the front line
where half a dozen people live
underground
and we see them emerge from the darkness
covered in soot and dirt
the police brought food and personal
towels for they haven't washed in weeks
what is it like what's it been like for
you
the people who live in this shelter
rarely leave it because it is the most
dangerous part of the city
they do their cooking here and the fire
keeps them warm but the air is difficult
to breathe
unsurprisingly they don't really care
who wins the war
there was one more task for the district
police at the end of a difficult day
with a small group of orphans to look
after
their carers had made arrangements to
send them to dinitro 400 kilometers to
the west are you excited about going to
dinitro yes
holmes better says alexei my dog is
there
officer barakov and his team say their
goodbyes as the regional governor warns
of a russian assault a matter of days
not weeks he says and severo donetsk may
bear the brunt
john sparks sky news in eastern ukraine